six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to the two four
eight area code two four rate can be
dicey historically two four eight can go
a couple different ways who's there at
two four eight hello my name is Harry
I'm from the Metro Detroit area all
right go ahead Harry okay so you know
before the 2016 election there was kind
of a worldwide increase the right wing
tendencies this year that's kind of
spread to Asia the Chinese president see
if spending term limits yeah and Prime
Minister obey has shown interest in
repealing Japan's equivalent of the
Fairness Doctrine right and so all these
kind of authoritarian swings on a macro
level if you're like there's kind of a
nice a like political crescendo is
something greater like do you think that
like these are some be worried about do
you think that these are just in
isolation or perhaps is there a sign
that something greater is going on right
very very good question so listen number
one to answer the first part of the
question
is this something we should be worried
about this sort of nationalist
right-wing movement that we seem to see
not only in parts of Europe but also in
parts of Asia we should be worried we
should be very very worried and we
should also be worried about writing it
off as some fluke look at marine lepen
and she got I don't know you know a
third of the vote in France we've seen
these right-wing nationalists even sort
of white nationalist type parties do
shockingly well in parts of Europe so
should we be worried the answer is yes
the second question is is it all
representative of the same trend and I
tend to think the answer is no so for
example the move in China for and I get
criticized for higher pronounce it
I believe it's Xi Jinping Xi Jinping I'm
doing it right this bumping like that
people say I don't know you that is
different than like a Danish white
nationalist party getting some percent
of support that's concerning to us so I
think that it's important not to mix it
all together and even though we should
be concerned about it all in total the
risk of considering it all part of the
same movement is that we start
to think the solution is the same in
China and the Philippines and and Poland
and it's and it's not so that's that's
where I would stop short okay thank you
for the the distinction upon and
actually I have a second question if
yeah please
so like this is like a while ago you
were on CNN when that one
like I guess crazy guy you interviewed
like I shot a place Glenn Miller yeah um
I'm kind of
yes Glenn Miller thank you I was kind of
wondering like since you were perhaps
for like an on-air corporate media sort
of thing yeah like what was the biggest
takeaway like what's the biggest
difference from like what you do now
versus like when you were kind of
prepped up for that segment yeah well I
mean there's a couple differences number
one is that you have absolutely no
contact whatsoever with the host until
five seconds before your live like
literally they you know a driver picked
me up that CNN sent and then someone met
me downstairs and they brought me to the
makeup room and they put makeup on me
and then an assistant producer it brings
me to the greenroom and then a segment
producer or stage manager brings me up
just off stage and then they literally
sit me down in front of Erin Burnett she
doesn't say a word to me in terms of hi
or whatever she's just literally reading
papers while I sit there and then five
seconds later were on the air and then
as soon as it's over I'm like rushed off
so it's stunningly impersonal which I
guess is not super surprising in the
sense that you know every second of that
show of all those shows is planned down
to the most minut detail I was not in
any way prepped or told anything content
wise like I was just like hey she's
gonna interview you about the fact that
you once interviewed this guy that's it
and I wasn't sort of like told stay away
from this or go towards that there was
nothing like that that took place so I
think the biggest difference was just
the total lack of any any kind of like
personal it was very very corporate in
every way you know mm-hmm yeah all right
thank you for the insightful answers all
right no problem appreciate that okay
thank you for calling